hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com
and for those who don't know me i'm a
professional trader for the past five
years and i've been working for several
big investment banks
like hsbc or commerce bank and i've just
started to make some youtube videos
where i want to explain you guys
everything i know about trading and how
to become a successful
trader so let's get into it
so in this video i want to talk about
golden rule number two
so golden rule number one to be a
successful trainer
is to have a good strict and proper risk
management
golden rule number two is to have
discipline all right if you don't have
discipline even if
the framework you built in your risk
management
is good but you're not able to follow it
because of your emotions because you
change your plan
because you actually lose control
then your risk management actually is
not
good so you need to be effective you
need to have
discipline let me tell you a story
about someone that i know that i know
very well
and that actually okay let's be honest
the guy this guy is me
all right and actually
i this was um something that happened to
me like few years ago
so i was training pa and i was
you know quite good at technical
analysis i was making some
money uh things were going well and i
entered the trade that was quite big and
i had like a stop loss
that i defined using technical analysis
with the trend line
actually and my stop loss got
broken so my position was stopped
what did i do i got back in the train
right away guys
right away why because i had too much
ego
i wanted to beat the market you know uh
i made it kind of
personal i let my my emotions
invade me completely and i changed my
plan i didn't stick to my initial
strategy um and i can tell you that this
was
a very dark period for me at this time
for those who know me they probably know
what i'm talking about
about this experience that actually last
few months and i was actually having
endless days
because i knew that i was stuck in the
trade i shouldn't be in
and i couldn't get out of it i couldn't
get out of it
i was stuck in this trade and i was just
looking at my portfolio getting
destroyed devastated
by every day by the strong moves that
were happening on the market that was
just dropping heavily
and the terrible thing is that i knew
that i shouldn't be in this trade
and i couldn't get out so you that's why
guys you really need
to stick to your plan never change
anything
that was planned before if you if you
choose
stop loss and a target it's for good
reasons otherwise you shouldn't be
doing training if you just choose it you
know randomly
there are reasons for this my stop loss
was very good
and after my stop-loss got broken the
market just got destroyed
and i was keeping my long position that
was my mistake i
learned of it and since then
i always always stick to my plan all
right
and there is another thing that is very
interesting for you guys to do
is actually to keep a record of your
trade this helps you to have discipline
all right
if you keep a record of your trades uh
you're gonna see
what kind of trades are profitable what
kind of trends are not
and for example if you do some day
trading you know you can have some
screen trading
like longer term some investments and
do some day trading and if you
are actually very rigorous and you
you take a note on everything you do
then you can compute your p
l of every action and you can see the
time you spend
and how much money it makes and
i can tell you that sometimes you have
the feeling that you are making money in
your day trading and then
at the end of the day you look at
everything you did you compute your p
l and you're going to see actually you
are losing all right
so then you need to get rid of it you
need to stop doing this you need to find
where you are good at
all right and the only way to actually
see it
is to have a record of every trade you
do and to compute your p
l so guys if you want to make money you
need to be like a pro
all right in the banking industry that's
what we do every trade is recorded every
trade
uh is followed and we we we check the
piano every day
and we don't change the plan all right
we don't change the plan
because all uh unless we have a very
good reason to do so
then we do it but this is the
professional
way to work right risk management
discipline
keep a record of your trades all right
there is a common mistake that people
often do
is um all right so either you don't
follow your stop loss so this was my
mistake for example
uh but you can also uh just buy the dip
how we call it or just double down you
know when the market goes against you
um you know we have something in
training we often say
is in trouble double all right because
usually when the market is going against
you
you buy the dip and then it comes back
yes all right
that's true but when it doesn't it's
a big loss that can occur to you guys
so do not do this uh i i don't like to
double down
uh my advice is don't do it if it's not
part of the plan if it's part of the
plan of course then it's fun you know
it's a good strategy to buy at different
levels
you know but then you need to buy 20 or
30 at the first level
and then 20 30 more at the next level
like five or ten percent lower
so on and so forth all right this is a
good strategy and this is part of the
plan then of course you do it but if
it's not
please guy guys don't do it the reason
why i'm talking about discipline
and to keep a record of your trades is
because it's the only way guys to find
actually a weakness we all have
weaknesses all right
and and by keeping a record of your
trades you actually can identify
what what went wrong we're not machines
guys
we're humans we have emotions all right
and those emotions when they come to us
they're gonna affect our trading and if
your emotions affect your trading
i can tell you guys that usually it's
because you're losing money
because you're anxious and this is a
very normal
feeling and to get rid of it you need
to um to put yourself in a machine mode
you know
that's the only thing to do you need to
get rid of those emotions
and they should not affect your
decisions your decisions should be made
um prior to your training and then you
stick to the plan
discipline record of your trades all
right guys
if you follow these rules i can tell you
that things will go
better much better that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and
once again if you did please do not
forget
to hit the like button and the subscribe
button so you're gonna be the first to
know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore